now if you filed your unemployment
claims this week but are wondering where
the money is we have an update
joe mohler live right now in the
newsroom with when you will get your
payment
and why they're behind joe yeah brian a
lot of people asking about this we did
reach out to dieter regarding these
payments and they say they should arrive
next week a representative initially
said
the delay was due to the holiday being
on july 5th well now the department says
pool payments
were simply not processed this week they
are now working to correct this problem
if you filed sunday your claim will be
processed tomorrow and payments should
be made next week now sal capano
says people have been looking for any
sort of answer for days now
really frustrated and also we know it
was a federal holiday um
here we are on thursday and in us
communication would be help us out a lot
at least people would know where we
stand how many people were affected and
what's
what's going on you know it's thursday
it's been three days
a lot of people frustrated all right
regular ui claimants are not affected by
this delay deters says they understand
the stress and pressure
the delay in benefits causes claimants
and are working on improvements
the department also says they are
working with their third party vendor
to avoid missing a payment like this
again reporting in the newsroom joe
mohler 8 news now